en Perú siguen las movilizaciones contra
la mandataria Dina boluarte los
fallecidos son al menos 62 desde la
destitución de Pedro Castillo a
principios de diciembre pero ya en
varias ocasiones la presidenta ha dicho
que no renuncia y que hay unidad en el
gobierno Cuáles son las perspectivas de
la gobernante la discusión sobre este
tema la vamos a tener con Katy y segarra
ella es politóloga de la pontificia
Universidad Católica del Perú Katy
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América y le pregunto por qué
Dina boluarte se permite afirmaciones
firmes de que no renuncia por menos de
lo que ha pasado en este mes y medio
tuvo que renunciar vizcarra y otros
mandatarios que duraron muy muy poco en
el poder
Y lamentablemente lo que estamos
observando es que hay una disociación
entre la realidad y lo que la mandataria
y en general los políticos tanto del
ejecutivo como legislativo tienen a mí
me parece sorprendente no solamente
desde la academia sino también en la
imagen que le estamos dando a la
ciudadanía de que un gobierno puede
mantenerse superando
más de 50 muertes no vinculadas a los
conflictos y a las protestas generadas y
generados especialmente para que para
que la presidenta
renuncie ahora está claro que la clase
política no solamente está desvinculada
con la ciudadanía sino también que está
impulsando una dialéctica en la cual se
busca terruquear o negar las
presentes
y demandas
no que si bien estas son heterogéneas
por ejemplo algunas personas piden hacer
la Constituyente entonces personas piden
la liberación de Pedro Castillo el
cierre del Congreso o demandas mucho más
antiguas e incluso algunos de ellos
están relacionados con
quizás con actividades ilegales lo que
estamos viendo en generales que si bien
estas demandas son heterogéneas y unen
el hecho de que Dina boluarte salga del
gobierno y como había señalado
previamente la política la clase
política en general no solamente estar
negando esa estas demandas estas están
intentando no escucharlas O no
Simplemente no la escuchan sino también
niegan la posibilidad de que estas
personas protesten no a través de la
violencia y aumenta así la polarización
recordemos de que la mayor cantidad de
personas que protestan vienen del Sur
del Perú y que además son personas
racial comercializadas no es que hacia
allá quería ir a la conversación solo
que usted me está respondiendo toda la
entrevista en la primera pregunta
es que mire Quisiera saber cuál es su
opinión sobre la movilización indígena
porque como siempre Al parecer la clase
política subestima a los Indígenas Cuál
es la capacidad de estos grupos
ciudadanos para mantenerse en pie en
este levantamiento social Ya vamos para
dos meses de protesta en los que
boluarte no ha sido capaz de ofrecer una
propuesta que calme las movilizaciones
seguimos viendo violencia en Lima y
seguimos viendo violencia en otras
provincias del país
sí veamos a ver Lamentablemente debido a
la centralidad que que caracteriza al
Perú
las protestas que sean en otro lado que
no sean la capital limeña pareciste que
no tuvieran el mismo impacto
el por ejemplo el breve gobierno de
Manuel Merino duró alrededor de una
semana y este finalizó debido a dos
muertos en la capital sin embargo ya ha
pasado más de 50 fallecidos alrededor
del Perú especialmente en la parte sur y
eso no ha significado claramente la
renuncia de inagoluarte
entonces muchos ciudadanos y ciudadanas
especialmente del sur han tenido que
movilizarse a la capital para intentar
ser escuchados por el gobierno y lo que
han recibido claro no solamente es más
violencia sino
han sido racializados y han sido negados
sus demandas son constantemente negadas
ahora lo que estamos viendo también es
que hay una parte
pues este de la ciudadanía que está
intentando ayudarlos por ejemplo
brindándoles abogados o brindándoles
alimentos y agua para que se mantengan
en la capital de hecho hubo una
actividad muy importante de parte del
del decano de la Universidad Nacional de
ingeniería que les ha dado la
posibilidad de que muchos alumnos que no
sean de de que vivan en en Lima y que se
y que estudien en esa universidad vengan
y se hospeden un tiempo en
la universidad Claro pero hasta hasta
eso ha sido un problema porque también
hubo allanamientos este fin de semana
recordemos hay más de 200 personas que
fueron detenidas y hablando un poco pues
de todo este este movimiento tan
heterogéneo que hay alrededor de Lima
los manifestantes pese a todo Siguen con
sus pedidos la renuncia de boluarte la
disolución del Congreso un llamado
inmediato de elecciones además de una
Constituyente alguno de esos pedidos en
su opinión están al alcance finalmente
mal hecho pero era lo que quería hacer
Pedro Castillo antes de ser destituido y
arrestado
creo que está el alcance el hecho de que
se puedan adelantar las elecciones al
menos hasta finales del año de de este
año ahora está claro que por ejemplo el
cierre del parlamento es una demanda no
democrática no Y la asamblea
Constituyente me parece que es una
en este momento No necesariamente
estamos en un momento Constituyente
en especial Porque Lamentablemente el
congreso peruano le ha puesto muchos
candados
a la ciudadanía que para por ejemplo
intentar cambiar la Constitución a
través del referéndum Entonces en ese en
este momento tenemos un escenario como
muy crispado en el cual depende de la
voluntad política del ejecutivo y el
legislativo pero especialmente
legislativo para que busque reducir el
tiempo y Llamar a elecciones lo más
pronto posible no sé si me parece que lo
que falta es presentar
e indicar a la ciudadanía de que estas
elecciones se pueden ser pueden hacerse
este año no y claramente
no solamente es el adelanto de
elecciones sino que creo además de que
en estos momentos la presencia viene a
volarte en el poder es Ya inadmisible
por la cantidad de fallecidos
presentados Sin embargo no se ve
perspectiva de una renuncia Por qué qué
es lo que hace diferente esta de mandato
de Dina boluarte al de los otros cinco
presidentes que han pasado por el país
en cinco años y que rápidamente han sido
expulsados por hechos tan graves o
incluso menos graves que estos
a ver
las caídas de los presidentes alta
crisis política
creo que se diferencia de este escenario
en particular por la cantidad de
fallecidos no decir hemos tenido
renuncias de por ejemplo el presidente
de Pedro Pablo puccinski renunció porque
ya sabían de que probablemente de que
era muy muy probable de que lo bajaron
luego el presidente vizcarra fue evacado
el presidente Manuel me dio fue también
inducido a renunciar por la muerte de
dos jóvenes y en el caso de Pedro
Castillo también fue evacado por
intentar generar un autogolpe de estado
Entonces si es que pueden observar las
razones tienden a ser o sea no son
iguales entre los casos en el particular
de Dina boluarte creo que se debe a que
en general no tiene una legitimidad
mínima para mantenerse en el cargo no es
decir
hay una gran mayoría de ciudadanos que
no se sienten representados por la
vicepresidenta a pesar que es legal es
decir que su entrada al gobierno ha sido
legal puesto que haya sido de la
vicepresidenta en esa plancha
presidencial sin embargo no no cuenta
con ese apoyo ciudadano y además de ello
el gran el el hecho de que ya hayamos
superado los 50 fallecidos creo que es
fundamental de que la presidenta
renuncie ahora esto significa el fin de
la crisis claramente no porque quien
tendría que asumir sería alguien un
parlamentario o parlamentaria que
presida la mesa la mesa directiva del
Congreso de la República lo cual además
es una institución muy poco común poco
de confianza ciudada